so the bigger question for me is if I am
and you are this unlimited intelligence
that transcends Concepts why does that
unlimited intelligence
engage in using concepts for me that's
the big question
this this is the well first of all
um you're in good company this is an
ancient level this is why this is why
does the one become Mini
if you're intrigued by the nature of
Consciousness its Origins and how it may
relate to physics meaning and purpose
then this conversation is a dream team
John verviki is an award-winning
lecturer at the University of Toronto
and a professor of cognitive science
Buddhism and psychology with
wide-reaching research advancing an
argument that explains the mindfulness
Revolution as well as the current
meaning crisis his lecture series the
meaning crisis is on YouTube and is
exquisite I highly recommend it if you'd
like to see one of the Brilliant Minds
of Our Generation sharing his process of
universal interpretation links as usual
to every reference in this podcast or in
the description Donald Hoffman is a
professor of cognitive science at UC
Irvine and is the author of the case
against reality Dawn argues that reality
is not what you see instead it's an
interface of icons Hoffman has appeared
on Ted co-authored over 100 scientific
articles and is back along with John
vervaki Don's previous appearance on
theories of everything this podcast
where we go over the mathematical
details of his conscious agent theory is
in the description as well as the other
podcasts with him with Don Hoffman and
yoshibak and also John vervaki has
appeared with yoshibak Jon has also
appeared with Bernardo Castro as well as
solo every episode is linked in the
description note that around the 30 35
minute Mark you'll hear two sponsors
Shopify and Masterworks they're brief
and I request that you don't skip as
watching them directly contributes to
this Channel having more quality
in-depth technical podcasts and we
select sponsors that we believe in and
right now there's a 60 second message
from our first sponsor brilliant if
you're familiar with toe you're familiar
with brilliant but for those who don't
know Brilliance is a place where you go
to learn math science and engineering
through these bite-sized Interactive
Learning experiences for example and I
keep saying this I would like to do a
podcast on information Theory
particularly Chiara marleto which is
David Deutsch's student has a theory of
everything that she puts forward called
Constructor Theory which is heavily
contingent on information Theory so I
took their a course on random variable
distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking at some point I'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order enjoy today's
theologusion with John vervaki and
Donald Hoffman we'll start off with
something new something new that you've
both learned in the past couple weeks
and the criteria is something that has
to be interesting to you clearly and
then it also should be relevant to the
conversation
so John why don't you start off
um what have I learned I've been reading
uh I've learned a lot I'm trying to
think of something that might be
relevant I don't know how this
conversation is going to go so
preemptive judgments of relevance are
extremely uh tricky If someone knows
relevance it's you
[Laughter]
it's like I love wisdom that doesn't
mean I'm wise
um
I've been reading uh an essay well first
an essay on nishit as they're saying
then nashida's essay on intelligibility
um and it's been very interesting to me
because I'm seeing a rather profound
convergence uh between Zen philosophical
Notions of intelligibility and the
neoplatonic ones and I'm finding that
um
I'm finding that a very powerful uh
because that kind of convergence says
something across cultures and time
you're getting that kind of convergence
lends plausibility to this examination
of intelligibility and as you know I do
a lot of work around what is
intelligibility
ETC so I think that will turn out to be
relevant uh to our discussion but I'm
I'm I I'm also really happy to see where
this discussion is is going to go I'm
really sort of excited to be here
talking with Donald and I I know he has
an extremely flexible mind so I'm I'm
just uh but I think intelligibility uh
might come up as a relevant topic great
I want to make a note for later you said
that you love wisdom but you're not sure
if you're wise I don't know does the
love of wisdom imply that you're wise
though
in the same way that loving what's good
implies that you're good no no that's
was exactly that was exactly my point my
the fact that I study relevance and I
love it doesn't mean I'm necessarily an
expert at enacting it
um in fact uh people often go into
psychology to study what they most lack
um and so I may actually be somebody
who's initially very I know within
social circumstances I've generally been
poor at picking up what's relevant uh
it's been something that I've been
learning over time very slowly
such as the curse of academics okay Don
well I've been um working on a paper on
relationship of Consciousness to physics
and so I've been thinking a lot about
that we're about to submit it uh this
week and
trying to show how we boot up space-time
and particle physics from a theory of
Consciousness and so one thing just as I
was driving yesterday
um
that I learned just by putting some
pieces together the physicists have this
notion about
um the vacuum and relationship to a
certain mathematical structure is called
permutations and they they relate them
the vacuum to the trivial permutation
and then particle interactions to these
non-trivial permutations called
decorative permutation and and I
realized in our friend yesterday so what
I learned was as I was reviewing the
mathematics of our mathematical
framework of Consciousness I realized
the dynamical aspect of conscious agents
that corresponds to the vacuum and it
corresponds to agents
um whose Dynamics
um is completely transient it they don't
talk to anybody else and they don't even
talk to themselves so they're they're
markovian Dynamics is completely
transient and that that was what
corresponds to what the physicists
called the vacuum state and so but all
of a sudden when I realized that it the
whole thing begins to make sense and so
so for me what was a big aha yesterday
was okay I I'm getting starting with
Consciousness trying to understand
particle scattering in physics as a
result of Consciousness and I understand
what the vacuum means that it actually
makes sense in the mathematical
framework we're dealing with so so I
guess it's relevant because if we end up
talking about Consciousness and
space-time and physics and physicalism
these kinds of Concepts will be very
very relevant
are you trying to study scattering
because you're inspired by nema's work
partly and I'm trying to study
scattering because ultimately
if we want to have a mathematically
precise scientific theory of
Consciousness that's going to be taken
seriously by the scientific World you've
got to make predictions that are
testable
and
a lot of my colleagues are thinking we
need to make predictions at the
Neuroscience level and of course we
eventually do but but but brains are
really complicated and uh particles are
very simple so my my goal is to make
predictions about two gluons in four
gluon out scattering first because not
because that's harder because it's
easier than neuroscience and the
physicists have already given us a way
into that so they they've said if you
want to do particle scattering
um
there are these structures beyond space
time like the amplitohedron and then the
deeper structures the decorated
permutations and so they say if you can
give us a decorative permutation we can
give you a scattering amplitude for some
kind of particle Dynamics and so what
I've been working on is is that starting
with the theory of Consciousness this
dynamical show how the decorative
permutations come out and from then I
can just then use all the wonderful work
by the physicists like Nema and his
collaborators that start with these
decorated permutations and give you
scattering amplitudes the big goal is to
start with Consciousness and make
predictions at colliders that are
testable and hopefully new predictions
that their current models can't make
right I would like to for example
explain why supersymmetry doesn't work
uh based on this dynamics of conscious
agents so so not just
of course we need to get all the stuff
that they've already done and we need to
be able to you know capture their
predictions that they've already tested
but we need to make new predictions as
well so that's why I was really working
on the scattering amplitudes because
one they're a way to empirically test
the theory number two we know this
really well we have the data we know
what the right answers are and we know
what the outstanding problems are and um
and and and then the fourth thing is I
would rather start there than
Neuroscience because it may seem
counterintuitive but but the scattering
is going to be much much easier than
making connections with Neuroscience
that are that are absolutely rigorous
and testable to you know 10 decibel
places or something like that
okay so the last broad question and then
I'm going to leave the floor open to you
both to riff off of one another is what
is it that you find impactful about one
another's work and we'll start Dawn with
you toward John and then John you'll
respond and then I'll interject fairly
seldomly
oh okay yeah well with John what's
what's beautiful is he's a one of those
rare truly Renaissance individuals who
who knows ancient philosophy and modern
philosophy you know modern Neuroscience
uh he knows evolutionary psychology he
knows um the scientific method backwards
and forwards but he also knows mystical
traditions and he knows how to pick and
choose from all of these in an
intelligent way to get a synthesis that
is then I think uh potentially
life-changing for many many people to
get meaning in our lives to understand
our current political situation and and
so he's one of those rare individuals
who who really knows this broad variety
of topics he knows how to integrate them
he's not just a dilettante but he
actually knows how to integrate them in
a transformative light and the other
thing I love is is
um his absolute demand for clean precise
logical thinking when you're thinking
but then he's welding in spiritual
Traditions to go into silence as well so
and I think both are absolutely
essential for the full human being and
the full human scientist
thank you Donald that was um
very kind and um
I um
that speaks to what I like about you
um right um I think you
I think you and I belong to the school
of what I like to call Big Picture
cognitive science which is not this or
that I mean you do specialist work and I
do specialist work but we we don't think
that's the core of good science that
integrating into a broad framework is
important and Frameworks like you that
try to bridge between uh like you do
like I do as well try to bridge you know
between a lot of the things that have
been vivisected off each from each other
in our society in our current scientific
worldview
um I think you asked big questions I
think you uh you I somebody who talks
about
Consciousness and Ultimate Reality and
yet wants to talk about it in a
scientifically rigorous even
mathematical formalized mathematical way
um you can see why I deeply resonate
with that I may not agree with all of
your particular conclusions uh and
that's to be said I mean do any two
academics uh but the point is
um uh I think if I can put it this way
in many important ways we're on the same
side of the tracks we think we should be
doing these Broad
uh Integrations that are not facile but
are pertinent precise well-arged for
well-evidenced
um and that they have important
existential sapiential and therefore
spiritual in that sense consequences
that should be respected uh we should
not limit
um the pool from which we're drawing our
analyzes to just sort of current
philosophy or current science but much
more broad cross-cultural across
historical cross-disciplinary
um so I mean
like I say
I'm sure we'll get into disagreement but
I I want to say this up front which is
the ma I often say this and I mean it
and people can see that I mean it and
how I uh how I
how I carry myself in discussions the
manner in which you're doing these
things I think is really really right in
a profound and important way
um and I think you you present it in a
way that's often
um very challenging to people who have
have a much more
I want to be kind here much more
specialized I was going to say blinker
but a much more specialized
um epistemology and I think that is
really needed now I think all
I'll speak for psychology we both are in
Psychology at least we both have a point
I have one in Psychology and cognitive
science you have one in Psychology and
other things too
um philosophy cognitive science but one
of the things that bothers me about
psychology is this emphasis on
innovation
um as opposed to integration I would
argue that's one of the things driving
the replication crisis and I think the
resistance to right creating
broad philosophically astute Frameworks
within psychology is something that
needs to be challenged and I see that
you and I are both doing that and I
think that's very very important you
know what let me ask a question so I'll
start this off with the perhaps the most
basic question we say that conscious or
some people say that Consciousness is
fundamental and then there's various
questions like well what is
consciousness so here's another question
what is fundamental so what's
fundamental if one doesn't assume
reductionism and if one does have to
assume reductionism for something to be
fundamental then does that mean that
conceptually reductionism is more
fundamental than the x that you're
saying is fundamental so anyway what is
fundamental
I'll be happy to start sure sure so I
think that
there's two important and different
concepts going on here one is
um reductionism which has to do with an
assumption about space-time being
fundamental
and with reductionism the idea is that
as you go to smaller and smaller scales
in space-time
you get to more and more fundamental
objects and more and more fundamental
laws
so that's a particular idea and by the
way reductionism is assuming uh um that
space-time itself is fundamental I mean
because it's taking smaller scales of
space as being associated with more and
more fundamental objects and laws
but fundamental for me is a much broader
concept than than say space time
fundamental is a property of scientific
theories so every scientific theory
um has assumptions
no theory in science is free of any
assumptions these assumptions are the
foundation of that scientific theory and
so what's fundamental is Vis it is is
with respect to a particular Theory what
what does that take as the fundamental
uh concepts for building that theory so
I I I think the notion of fundamental is
a theory
relative concept you should ask
um what's fundamental in this particular
scientific theory in Einstein's theory
of gravity space time is fundamental in
uh you know Evolution Financial
selection we have the notion of physical
objects in space-time and things like
genes and competition and replication
those are those are fundamental concepts
in in that theory but you can have uh
different scientific theories with with
different fundamental concepts most of
modern science does take
space-time as fundamental but then
they'll also add other
other Concepts as well to be fundamental
like in evolution you'll also add
organisms and DNA and replication and
and so forth so but and so most
scientific theories also inherit the
assumption that reductionism is is a
good method most of them do um
I'll just I'll turn it over to John but
I'll just say that physicists now are
saying that space-time is not
fundamental like Neymar economed and
others and that therefore reductionism
um is is doomed not just space-time but
reductionism is is doomed
um but I'll stop there
so I agree with I think I'm agreeing
with Donald that
um I would want to distinguish uh
reductionism from claims of
fundamentality
um I think productionism is very
problematic
uh it has uh it gets you into certain
performative contradictions if you try
to make an absolute complete
reductionism because it gets you into
saying things like only the bottom level
is real and I know that from this level
up here which isn't real you get all
kinds of performative contradictions
going on there you have measurement
problems uh Wolfgang Smith has brought
this out you know the the ruler can't be
a Quantum thing to measure the Quantum
of things or you get into and I I won't
review that there's a host of problems
where I think reductionism and and a
completely flat ontology aren't uh
justifiable briefly why do you say
performative contradiction and not
contradiction performative contradiction
means that there isn't a contradiction
between propositions there's
contradictions between the activity and
the proposition stated performance
here's one I'm asleep right now
okay that doesn't make any sense or to
perform a contradiction because the
action
requires the the falsity of the
proposition right so can you explain why
suggesting that there's some ground
that's more real than a higher level is
a performative contradiction
ah
what I was saying is if you if you say
that the bottom level is the only level
that's at re with real that is clearly
not the level at which the science is
being done the science is being done by
scientists using gauges and writing
things down and using computers and
using language and making theories and
going to conferences and if all of that
is not real because it's somehow
epiphenomenal or illusory then how is it
that that level is giving you epistemic
access to the real bottom level you're
saying like it's be like saying I'm in
the middle of a dream and in that dream
I I dreamed that Santa Claus was real
therefore Santa Claus is real like if if
you if the level at which you're doing
this science is illusory it undermines
all the claims you're making from that
level you have to be able to give it on
tall on ontological reality to science
if any of its conclusions are going to
be taken to be real that's beautiful
thank you so that's I and there's a host
of other arguments and I I want to put
reductionism aside for that now
fundamental and I agree with Donald
completely fundamental is a theoretic
um but one thing you can be connoting
not denoting is what you think is the
the ontological referent uh which is
what some people sometimes mean by
fundamental and I I think instead of
using fundamental which is a theoretic
property we might want to use an
ontological property like real and then
you might be asking what is it to say
that something is real or to say that
one thing is more real than another and
I think that is an important question
and I think that question can't be
decided by just looking within any
particular theory for its particular
fundamentals because what we're asking I
think I would argue when we're asking
questions about reality is what what
makes possible any and all such
intelligibility what makes possible any
possible theory that might turn out to
be true there has to be some aspect
because we take it I think that reality
in some sense corresponds to
our ability to make our claim to find
our claims true or our skills apply
applying or a perspectives present
Etc so I I'm waving over with that with
my hand because that's a big thorny knot
but I'm trying to pull apart I think
there's reductionism which we put aside
there's fundamentality and I will I
agree with Donald what he just said
about that and but I think we have an
extra theoretic notion which is the
notion of realness which is something
like that which can make you know
various theories true how do they do it
and then the question might be are you a
pluralist or modest about that for
example that might be a starting point
do you think there are many different
realities that make theories too you
could be some kind of relief to this in
that way or do you think that there is a
Ultimate Reality in some important
unified fashion Etc so there there's
three different questions we could be
asking reductionism which I I'd largely
put aside what's the fundamental of any
Theory but you might ask what's reality
and you might ask it in saying what is
it that could possibly integrate
non-reductively all these fundamentals
together so that we would have an over
our integrated coherent account
that's those those are the kinds of
moves you can make
did that make sense
sure so don
do you have anything to say in response
I think that
you know the notion of reality is an
extra notion Beyond just what's
fundamental to a particular Theory
the the and this whole area is very very
tricky you know for the very kinds of
performative contradiction reasons that
John just mentioned yeah very very easy
to step on landmines everywhere here but
it seems to me that that
girdles in completeness theorem
tells us that in some sense there is no
Theory of Everything
right any formal system that is Rich
enough to model the axiom's arithmetic
is is either inconsistent or incomplete
and we call it girdles in completeness
theorem because we don't take the
inconsistency thing too seriously so
that means no matter what
scientific theory we have
it's not the final word there'll always
be if the if the theory is Rich enough
to do arithmetic and most scientific
theories are they wouldn't be taken
seriously so they're rich enough to do
arithmetic so they're rich enough to
have a girdle statement that uh that is
outside their scope and yet is true
um but not provable within that theory
and and no matter how much you add those
new statements to your your scientific
theory they'll always be new statements
that that so that that means that are
there there is no scientific theory of
everything
and the notion of Truth and and and I
think the related notion of reality and
that's why I'm bringing this up the
notion of Truth and and the notion of
reality in some sense I think will
forever transcend
scientific theory and of course I'm a
scientist so I'm not saying oh throw up
our hands and yeah there's something
very deep going on here that that that
that that
theories turn out to be empirically
quite valuable right we were I'm alive
today because of scientific theories
that that led to medicine that have
saved my life so so the you know the
stuff works even though girl tells me
that it that it's um the theory is
Trivial compared to the truths that the
theories uh can't prove right so so
there so the fact that you can't have a
theory of everything
um and you can't ultimately
know that the truth with a capital T and
therefore and this is where John may
want to disagree I don't know therefore
we can't know what what's reality with a
capital R we can only say these are the
best theories we have so far but we need
to modestly and humbly say um that's our
Theory that's not the truth and I would
be fooled to say that that's the reality
um so I would but I should probably stop
and let John react I just want to thank
Donald for being I hope I I follow his
example and continually make space for
him as well yeah okay great great so
apologies for me not making space here
for taking some space so with girdles in
completeness theorem he said that we may
never know truth with the capital T and
then you said that a toad may not exist
however there's the difference between a
toe existing and US knowing the toe and
when you said that we don't know truth
with the capital T to me that truth with
a capital t is the same as the toe
that's a statement then I'll get you to
respond to that and then second is that
there are certain assumptions in
girdle's theorem so for instance that
the laws would have to be based in first
order logic or that the laws are
consistent because consistency is
actually an implicit requirement and
it'd be strange to say that the world is
inconsistent though there are some
people who I'm sure on the more Mystic
end who may say that reality is a
contradiction paradoxes are at the
bottom and the top and there's no bottom
and top but there is
well those are some ways of getting
around it and that's why when I hear
people like myself maybe even two years
ago would say girdles incompleteness
theorem says there is no toe uh that's a
bit dubious to me so I want to hear what
are your responses to that and then John
so please then comment
I like I'd like to hear Donald's
response to that first
right well so I I would say your point
is about taking Kurt the way I would
think about it is to say
the fact that we can't have a theory of
everything doesn't mean that there isn't
a truth out there
a a real a real true reality
and from spiritual traditions we learned
that that perhaps um that's what you are
you're not divorced from that reality
you are that reality and and you can't
know that reality through intellectual
and conceptual knowing but you can know
it firsthand by being that reality and
so and so so there could be this notion
of truth and reality
uh that transcends the notion of a
theory of everything see a theory of
everything starts off with a finite set
of Concepts and and says here's how far
I can go with this set of Concepts
um and so my my argument would be you
know along the lines of girdles kind of
argument that if you start with any
finite axiomatization or any finite set
of Concepts you can come up with an
infinite number of theorems absolutely
you can come up with an infinite number
of theorems but there will be
probability zero compared to all the
truths that that that that that are out
there
um and so that's why I would I mean but
again there's this meta notion that John
was bringing up so I'm I'm here I am
talking about Truth uh using words
um and but but saying the concepts
themselves have very limited meaning the
the only
Escape out of it is for me is is this
issue that
um the spiritual Traditions bring up
which is um
you can't talk about the truth but you
are it your very being is it and and so
when you when you speak that being
itself is projecting down into a finite
set of Concepts to talk with with other
avatars of the being
um but and and so I think that there's a
way not to be self-refuting
um in that but I again I would love to
have John contradict me I I don't know
if I'm going to contradict you or not
um
yeah I I
think the go to argument still has value
with respect to formal systems
um whether or not theories are formal
systems I think it's a genuine
philosophical question
um I think you know we clearly had
theories before there was math and their
bona fide theories Plato has a theory of
the psyche and whether or not you could
call that a formal system
um I think is is questionable
um and yet there was a lot of I would
say there's a lot of Truth in Plato's uh
Theory it turned out to be you know it's
been got quite a bit of empirical
confirmation uh recently so
um so I'm a little bit hesitant about
that but I take your point to be correct
uh Donald in fact I take it very deeply
and I actually think this is a platonic
point and this is something that comes
out in plania's work as well I take one
of the ways in which we determine that
something's real is precisely it it's
inexhaustibleness
um it's but it's not cacophonous and
exhaustibility and this is the thing
this is what I think Plato meant by the
good we get it's in it everything is an
inexhaustible fount of intelligibility
we can learn more and more so I do not
think there is a limited number of
truths about anything I think the number
of true even the number of true
descriptions of this very plain Stone
um is indefinitely large it's
inexhaustible
um Etc and this is what I talk about
multi-spectuality and things like that
so I don't think of
um I don't think I'm disagreeing with
you because I think that being an
inexhaustible fount of intelligibility
is precisely one of the ways in which we
determine that something is real uh and
um and I think that for phenomenological
reasons and for uh for cognitive reasons
I also think
that
um truth is a retrospective notion
um like real it's a comparative notion
um so when I say something's real or
something's an illusion I'm always
making a comparison when I say this is
true what I'm really saying
um is this is more true than that
because here's the limitations that that
have that I can see from here but I'm I
I I I right I'm a fallibalist that
doesn't mean that I then conclude oh
this Theory I can stop here because no
theory has ever done that and there's no
good reason to believe so right I'll
come to I'll have another transformative
moment where I'll say oh but that theory
turns out to be limited because of this
and to what do I point to that the
entire history of science the entire
history of science shows that to be the
case again and again and again and I
think that's the notion I think the
notion of Truth we're using is a
retrospective comparative notion
um I don't think that that means it's an
illusion I think we should give up the
Cartesian notion that truth points to
some complete absolute formalized grasp
of something and that the Criterion of
knowledge is certainty uh and because
we've tried that and it collapses it
certainly doesn't underwrite science uh
because you know it's it's very
plausibly the case that many of our
current best theories will turn out to
be rejected in the future right this is
Lawton's uh you know pessimistic
argument I think it has to be taken very
seriously now the last thing that Donald
said and what I think with him is
convergent with everything I just said
send Shivers up my spine because you
know I've been I've been arguing that
there are kinds of knowing other than
propositional inferential there's
procedural there's perspectival and
there's participatory which is knowing
by being and I agree that many of these
mystical Traditions say you know the the
way to come in most contact with reality
is not through your conceptual
propositional knowing but it's through
your perspectival and all ultimately
your participatory knowing and I agree
that that that
is always the case give me a moment here
what I mean by that is something like
what Marla Ponte or or 40 Cox I would
say right is
even my propositional things are
ultimately dependent on skills my skills
are dependent on perspectives my
perspectives are always dependent on
participatory identity and so the
spiritual Traditions are not they're
just explicating something that is
always the case they're not proposing
something that's over there that only
only the great gifted ones can realize
um I mean that's part of I think what's
a little bit wrong with the way some of
these spiritual Traditions have been
taken up right but I think what the
spiritual Traditions are pointing to is
exactly that fact that that there's a
there's an asymmetric dependence
relation the propositional is dependent
on the procedural the procedural is
dependent on the perspectival and the
perspectival is dependent on the
participatory and so for me I try to
understand realness in terms of what
best integrates those four together
um when we're making claims of about how
things are
well very good very very good
now just a brief note from two sponsors
many of you are more than passive
listeners with variegated interests from
science to engineering to video games to
virtual reality you may even have your
own business or wish to start one well
it's the 21st century where you can
create a website in under an hour and
start selling products to virtually
every country on the planet businesses
like Shopify make that process intuitive
simple and comprehensive with libraries
of tutorials 24 7 support and to be
frank it's one of the most pleasing to
the eye eCommerce sites out there
whether you're into making ebooks or
earrings Shopify has made hundreds of
millions of dollars for entrepreneurs
around the globe starting a business is
a considerably challenging Adventure
that takes you through growth life
lessons and can potentially pay off in a
life-changing manner the emergence of
Shopify as a major player in the
e-commerce space has been remarkable I
invite you to explore Shopify and
welcome them as a sponsor of toe sign up
for a free trial at shopify.com theories
that's all lowercase go to shopify.com
theories to start selling online line
today that's shopify.com theories
as the tow project rolls we get plenty
of sponsors coming and I thought you
know this one is a fascinating company
our new sponsor is Masterworks
Masterworks is the only platform that
allows you to invest in multi-million
dollar works of art by Picasso bansky
and more Masterworks is giving you
access to invest in Fine Art which is
usually only accessible to
multi-millionaires or billionaires the
art that you see hanging in museums can
now be partially owned by you the
inventive part is that you don't need to
know the details of art or investing
Masterworks makes the whole process
straightforward with a clean interface
and exceptional customer service they
are innovating as more traditional
Investments suffer last month we
verified a cell which had a 21.5 percent
return so for instance if you were to
put ten thousand dollars in you would
now have twelve thousand Welcome to our
new sponsor Masterworks and the link to
them is in the description just so you
know there's in fact a wait list to join
their platform right now however total
listeners can skip the wait list by
visiting the link in the description as
well as by using the promo code theories
of everything again the link is in the
description you can see important
regulation A disclosures at
masterworks.com CD
I agree I like the idea that the truth
is related to some kind of inexhaustible
uh Arena that where you can keep
learning and and
I also in the case of scientific
theories and the relationship to that
notion of Truth
for me what's impressive about a
scientific theory is when it predicts
its own demise uh yes sorry for
interrupting sorry yeah
that that's for for me A scientific
theory is one that that when you really
understand the theory it tells you the
limits of its Concepts and it tells you
where it stops and it tells you that at
this point you will need uh not just a
tweak you will need a new framework
yeah you will need a new set of
foundational Concepts
and but the the nice thing about science
in this regard is that the constraint is
whatever new framework that you if this
current theory is is one that we take
seriously like like Einstein's theory of
gravity or Quantum filtering right and
it tells you its limits or evolution by
natural selection and this theory that
we say okay right now this is one of the
best theories Humanity has ever had
and and we look for its limits
when we get the new deeper Theory with
new
conceptual framework perhaps
we don't just pick that willy-nilly and
however we want there is a constraint
our old theories can't tell us what's
beyond they can tell us that there's
something Beyond but they can't tell us
what is beyond but they can veto our bad
ideas so what we have to do is build our
new framework with new Concepts and then
we need to show
that there is some kind of projection a
simplified sub-model of our new more
General model gives us back evolution by
natural selection or it gives us back
Quantum field Theory and space time
that's that's the constraint if we can't
do that or when we project it back we
get something that includes Evolution
and a little bit more for example it
could be an augmented theory of
evolution it doesn't be exactly but it
better not lose anything that we know
and love from evolutionary theory or
better tell us in convincing ways why we
were mistaken about that aspect of it
right so so that's the constraint so so
I I see truth in in
and the real as uh you know
you know these absolute things that
there are Concepts will never they will
scratch the surface but they will never
probe the depths
and what science is and and of course
even you know
uh pre-scientific theories like like
Plato's for example as you mentioned
what these theories are doing is using
Concepts to to explore yes truth and and
there with with science what we get
that's new
is
precise mathematical precise statements
of the limit of the theory and and what
a wonderful
[Music]
um cure for dogmatism because when your
own Theory tells you its limits if you
buy the theory you have to buy the
limits and so you have to buy that you
don't have the final answer and that's
that's really uh so that's the cure for
dogmatism so so theories that I love a
theory where the theory itself is humble
enough to tell you where it stops and
but but also smart enough to be able to
veto any bad ideas you have for what's
next
on that note where do you both see your
own theories indicating their limits
well first of all I want to reply to
what Donald said because I think he just
put his finger on something that I've
been arguing and I think there's a point
of convergence here
we put a lot of emphasis on coherence
and other features for our understanding
of rationality but I think this capacity
to do what Donald has just argued which
is a genuine capacity to afford
principled self-correction vetoing
things out and then pointing Beyond
um I think this is a Hallmark of
rationality that is not emphasized
enough and this is but I often tell my
students even at a heuristic level
if you want to assess somebody's
rationality look how much they are
willing to criticize their own work at
some point or correct their previous
work I don't expect it in like in in the
moment they're talking because that's
but like can they because can they look
at something they did a year or two ago
and go oh here's all the mistakes in
there right
um and that I think is really really
important now
um
I I think
um
I think what I would say is that and
then I'll I'll ask you to re-ask your
question Kurt if if you want to change
it modify but for me therefore
um truth is like Notions like
orientation and navigation
um you're properly oriented and the
orientation rules a lot of things out
we're not going that way we're not going
that way we're not going that and then
navigation is constantly telling you how
you have to adjust and reformulate how
you're doing and you might find from the
navigation that you need to reorient
right that's a pro and that's always a
possibility but that's not the same as
wandering around willy-nilly right
there's a there's a very big difference
and so that's what I meant when I think
truth is always retrospective you can
always look back and say hey look at how
far we have rely we are closer we we may
have to change our Direction but we've
made genuine on you know I'm using the
spatial metaphor here progress and so
that's what I think is really crucial
um
I
this may sound like I I I I'm splitting
a hair
but I want to argue that I'm not because
this notion of Truth as orientational
and navigational rather than as a
completed grasp of something I think is
really really important right now and I
think we really have to pause and and
and and for example let me just say one
thing and then I'll shut up unless you
let you re-ask your your question but I
just wanted to pick up on this point
because Donald was saying something
about theories and I think it directly
also corresponds to how we should
understand rationality
um and and so
if what he said is true and I agree it
is and what I'm saying is true that
means that there are a lot of and this
is ties back again to what the spiritual
Traditions can hold out for us there are
a lot of truths that are not accessible
to US unless we're willing to undergo
significant transformation
right once you give up oh no I can just
grasp this thing with this Universal
method leibniz's calculus once you give
that up and you say no no no there's
going to be this constantly going on
that the demand like the the
presupposition that you can sort of
Remain epistemically the grammar of your
uh of your epistemic Machinery can
remain unaltered in order to get access
to truth I think that is uh deeply
challenged if not outright falsified but
that presupposition of a universal
method is that does not require personal
transformation is fundamental to the
whole Cartesian framework and see I
think the spiritual Traditions are there
reminding us that no no no your methods
can do a lot but there's a lot of truths
that are only disclosable to you after
you go through profound self-correction
which is profound self-transcendence
which is profound transformation I just
wanted to make that point very clear
well I I like your question that's
pending so we'll I want to get to it
about the limits of our own theories but
please but it is transformative so yes
it's not you can't just be a brainer
Nevada is the whole person that's that's
involved in this process and
for example letting go of physicalism
the idea that space-time is doomed for
example so this is just in the last 20
30 years physicists are saying space
time is doomed and that's not a trivial
thing to say when you say space time is
doomed what what goes along with that is
amazing both mathematically
scientifically but also personally
and and it hurts because
most of of us as physicalists then think
of ourselves as our bodies I am my body
that's that is what I am and my
conscious experiences just are for
example what my brain produces and
that's what I am
and that's part of that whole I mean
that's an implica a clean implication of
the physicalist framework you are your
body and when your your brain dissolves
um whatever Consciousness you may have
you may think Consciousness is an
illusion I'm good friends of mine uh for
example Keith Frankish thinks that the
Consciousness in delusion or Dan
so so
that Consciousness whether it's real or
illusory is gone when your body dies
that's a but if you let go of
physicalism it's not just uh okay I just
changed a few assumptions no no who I am
is now up for grabs I was just a body in
space-time
now I cannot be a body in space-time
because space-time is not fundamental so
what am I so now it's not just this
intellectual dispassionate it's who I am
as an individual that's up for grabs and
so that becomes very emotional too you
you have people get afraid sometimes
when I talk about
we don't see reality as it is and and
space-time isn't fundamental people
throw out a a few key counter points and
when I answer them all of a sudden I see
fear and and that's this personal aspect
of this thing this is not just an
intellectual brain in the math thing it
becomes very personal and so your whole
not only intellectual but emotional
assessment of who I am and all that that
means
he is also at stake here so I agree with
John that that's it's very
transformative it's not just writing
theories down and dispassionately
looking at them
okay well let's speak about a mental
health aspect here because when we're
referring to changing one's identity
then it sounds like that's all
some process of Enlightenment and
salutary if you wrote only to push
through the fear but then there's also
psychosis and derealization and
depersonalization and generally in these
more spiritual discussions I don't hear
much about the negative aspects of these
transformative experiences or of
contending with ideas I know for myself
I haven't looked this up but people told
me it was like a dark night of the Soul
so I still have to look that up and the
reason I haven't looked it up is because
at the time it was too close to me I
couldn't even look up I was afraid that
I had every mental illness like I
thought do I have schizophrenia to have
I don't even know what that is I still
don't know what that is so I have to
talk to psychiatrists and therapists and
find out and they said no you have
anxiety like you have extreme anxiety
you gotta quiet down and also then they
said hey Kurt in these comments like I
read the comments and people say that
what you had was an Awakening experience
where I felt like everything was in my
head it was like solipsism and
frequently my grasp of reality was so
tenuous and my identification with my
body was so loose and
it wasn't pleasant in the least but then
in the comment section I hear people
saying and I imagine that they're well
intentioned they would say like you need
to push through that the hero encounters
and the hero doesn't run away and then
it's making me feel like a coward like
I'm this person that this Requiem Craven
gutless and invertebrate so I was
speaking to a therapist and she said you
know firstly this idea of the hero that
encounters that's a bit dangerous
because it can give you this hero
complex and secondly you are
encountering it by coming by voluntarily
coming to therapy and doing exposure
therapy so she's like hey read those
comments read them realize that they're
just words on a page go closer to them
like various exercises so I do that and
like geez Louise like looking at my
fingers and feeling like I have fingers
that's salutary for myself for some
other people they could say that well
suffering comes from an identification
with the ego or the body for me all my
pleasure like every
the beautifulness of life is finally
back and it's like back at a more deep
rich level than it ever was it reminds
me of this quote about T.S Eliot like
you come back to the place and you know
it for the first time I don't feel as if
I've completely transformed like a note
for the first time I certainly am seeing
it differently and experiencing it
differently maybe that's what he meant
anyway so the more nefarious aspects of
the meditation or whatever we think of
as meditation in the west so our
misinterpretations of Eastern or just
adoptions of certain practices without
the whole Community around it and these
lessons of Enlightenment and so on they
can be extremely propitious for many
people but then also dire for many
others and I don't hear much of that
negative aspect and then recently it
happened upon the work of Anna Let
kajtis so forgive me Anna if I'm
mispronouncing your name
she's a PhD candidate from Sydney and
her work was brought to me by Shoshanna
Jones Square who's a professor at the
University of Bishop if I'm not mistaken
anyway Anna studies the Dark Side of
Dharma and so I want to interview her I
guess an overarching question is what
terrifies you about your work
I want to answer that right
um
first of all if you look in these
traditions and when I teach meditation I
do the same thing they warn about all
kinds of things that can happen to you
the it's only when the you get the
Western importation of these
um and the and and the commodification
that says there's a Panacea practice
there's a single practice you can do
that will bring you Bliss or something
and I think this is pernicious [ __ ]
um I do not think you know from my
understanding of how cognition works
that there is anything like a Panacea
practice and I've had enough Traditions
with many kinds uh sorry enough
experience with many Traditions that
there are stuff that goes really like
really challenges you in in ways you
said you can and by the way it's from St
John of the Cross Dark Knight of the
Soul
um
right
um and he wrote it for good reason
um I think
what you need
and I've argued for this elsewhere Kurt
so I won't repeat all the arguments but
you need an Ecology of practices that
sits within a community of people
so that when the dark [ __ ] happens you
have people there with you you have
other practices that can prevent you
from spinning off that's why you went to
therapy therapy was a a
compensatory practice that brought you
into realignment with the anomalous
experiences so you were able to
integrate it so I think uh
I think we have to be really careful I I
take the criticism well and by the way
people have been doing this for a while
look at the work of Willow Barton she's
done work on some of the the dark stuff
that comes out in mindfulness practices
and one of the things that and and this
is telling
so I I was at a conference and she was
doing this and I hope this does not come
off as self-promotional because that's
not the intent
she was saying this and I put up my hand
and I say but I always warn my students
that they're going to get these weird
things when they're meditating they're
going to get really cold or really hot
they're going to feel that they're
floating or Sinking and they might feel
disconnect like I warn them about all of
that and you know and how to incorporate
it in and then and then she sort of
looked at me strangely and I said look
don't most instructors in the west warn
people about all of this she said no
they don't
right
now that to me is the most empirically
relevant fact not the Traditions is that
there's something going on in Western
culture with its commodification and its
Comfort zoning that precludes people
doing this on a regular reliable basis
when we have clear historical evidence
that in situ these traditions did this
on a regular and reliable basis and so
I'm not saying that there aren't Dark
Knights of the soul but you don't have
to be isolated alone feel that you're
going insane like you you could have an
Ecology of practices and a community and
a tradition that allows you to properly
and I don't say push through because for
every hero myth there's a hubris myth
you don't push through this you have to
you have to listen to other people
really deeply at that point you had to
listen to your therapist right that's
what it's really indicating but this
individualistic commodified comfort zone
way in which we've appropriated
spirituality I think that is where I
would point the critical finger we like
by like this is one of the I think this
is one of the symptoms of the The Mating
crisis you know 40 of the population
have these anomalous Visionary mystical
experiences and they have no they have
nothing right that allows them to
incorporate it into their lives
but that's that's not a generalized
feature of all human civilization or
culture that is specific to ours in a
way I think that really reflects the
meaning crisis so I think we speak to it
but I think we speak to it while making
this criticism that I just made
yeah
I I agree and and I uh would just add
that
in meditation but you're what you're
doing is we all have a model of Who We
Are
I have my beliefs about what I am
and most of those beliefs are false
right so I am my body I I am
um what's what makes me important is I
am a professor or I'm an artist or or
and what my significance comes from how
many people have seen my work or what
people are saying about my work so we I
I identify Who I Am with some
thing some body some piece of work some
reputation and so forth and and the
spiritual practice is I think
a practice of
letting you know no that's not what you
are now that is going to be extremely
painful because
effectively
if I am that thing and I'm having to let
that go I'm dying and I am I am
experiencing a death because I thought I
was that and the spiritual birth comes
at the price of the death of the old
thing I thought I was
and I I believed it very very deeply so
I'm emotionally attached to that view of
myself I'm emotionally attached to the
idea that it's important for me to be
famous or to be the best musician or to
whatever my whatever my thing might be
I'm attached to all those things and the
fear that I that you experience
and for me
um I just expect this on a daily basis I
expect to experience fear because I'm in
the process of letting go of deeply held
um false identifications of who I am
that have you know and I don't blame
myself we're born with them and I I was
trained in them and now it's time to to
grow up and let them go and so I just
expect on a daily basis to um to face
pain and in fact it's when the pain
comes up that I go okay ah here's here's
my chance to really grow so I look at
the pain okay what identification with
some false belief about who I am do I
need to face now oh oh I really believe
that it's really important so someone
cuts me off on the road I'm driving why
do I get upset okay so there's all the
whole okay I believe I'm a separate
person from that other person
for example that's one of my first
beliefs is that true
or is it true that there's only one of
us
so there's all sorts of beliefs that I
have to to to to to face and in the
Christian tradition I mean it's you know
mostly you see this in the East where
you're doing this kind of thing but but
I think even Jesus spoke to this when
when he said if anyone will come after
me they have to take up their cross
daily
um you know and die basically you know
every day so if and that's what the way
I view it I'm dying to my old model of
myself
and it hurts because I really believed
it and I'm having to let go of all these
old beliefs that I that I have had for
for decades perhaps and so it's they're
not just intellectual they're limbic
there's emotions attached to them and so
it's a very visceral kind of thing and
so anxiety comes up out of it and so as
I face them and and really
face them and and Curt you know being in
your body is important because that's
where you so I I get in my body and
really really feel it don't turn away
from it and and then often
um you know
it doesn't need to be intellectual but
it just needs to be present but
eventually I will often see aha there
was that same old belief and Okay the
reason I'm in pain is because I believe
I'm that and that's false and I don't
want to let go of it it hurts to let go
of that and it's it's scary because I'm
going from what I thought I knew into
something that I don't know so it's also
the it's the fear of death and the fear
of the unknown wrapped up into one
wonderful ball and that's what we have
to do is to face the fear of the death
of what we know and the move into the
unknown
that we don't know and so there's two
fears and it's and it really is
um so I my feeling is that that's not a
side that's part of the whole practice
and and you should be told up front that
that's what it is to grow spiritually
it's to face that fear of those two
fears and to face them head on and to
get help when it's too too painful right
for most of us it's really helpful to
have someone else who's maybe let go of
that particular fear and gone into that
particular part of the unknown that can
sort of help us and take us by the hand
and move us along
foreign
it's at this point that I recommend you
watch the toe podcast with Lily and
dindo and Carl friston part two for more
help with dealing with derealization and
depersonalization that is for help when
subsumed by the dark side of the
spiritual journey links in the
description
I just also thank you Donald I don't
have any disagreement with that
um I uh I just wanted now to go back to
your question about what and I mean I've
I'll point to I mean if you go in my
series I criticized earlier models of
wisdom that I had published uh if people
want to see me doing that
um I recently came when in the summer to
out of interacting I was at um Maple
with the respond Retreat and there was
uh interacting with the Buddhist monks
there and um and I came to sort of an
Insight
uh that made me realize that that there
was something that was an important
dimension of my thinking that had been
wrong or at least incomplete and there's
Godel again
um so as you know I'll assume people
know because they've been here and I
have this idea about relevance
realization as a central feature of
cognition and intelligence and even uh
Consciousness
um
um and I'd always assumed that
there was a sense in which it was always
always being presupposed
uh but I realized
and
that
relevance realization can come to a
state if that's even the right word at
least where it realizes its own
irrelevance
and we we have to take it that relevance
realization has some recursive ability
because that's what we see in an Insight
we realize that a previous pattern of
relevance realization is actually wrong
irrelevant so the recursivity is built
into relevance realization but it can
come to realize that that not just this
or that but that it itself is irrelevant
and that would be when it is no longer
trying to work with beings but with
being itself capital B because then
relevance realization is actually
irrelevant because it makes it it right
because all you do is start to do this
is like the Dao right you start to
parse it out and then you get the
combinatorial explosion that relevance
realization has to deal with but
relevance realization can come to a
moment where it realizes that it's
irrelevant and fall away and that is
when you are trying to enter ratio
religio right relationship with being uh
with the ground of being per se and I
and for me
that was a way
of taking something that I had been
experiencing and talking a lot about
within
the mindfulness practices which is
experiences of non-duality and the work
I've always done on relevance
realization I couldn't put them together
um and so I and what I had to do was I
had to like run like like like uh that
Donald's just saying is I had to give up
right a kind of it's always relevance
realization kind of idea but that
actually there's a possibility for it to
functionally find itself irrelevant and
then opening us up phenomenologically to
no set of beings but to being or the
ground to being depending on your
ontology per se and then the point there
isn't any cognitive grasp but to be as
connected with it as you possibly can so
that's just an example of an important I
considered that an important correction
um
Terror
I'm afraid that my work especially the
stuff I've recently just published a few
months ago integrating relevance
realization and predictive processing is
going to make AI like autonomous AI more
really more possible
um and that
terrifies me uh um
and and not just sort of egocentric
Terror like moral Terror like a a a
sense of of moral responsibility are
those ever the same
some people would say that anytime we
think of morality it comes from a sense
of ego and that as soon as you dissolve
the ego you dissolve morality there is
no good there is no bad so when you say
that it's not an egocentric manner but a
moral manner that that I I I I am very
hesitant to uh say that morality is
egocentric in in too core are there
theories of morality that are uh yes but
uh I think there are theories that are
antocentric rather than egocentric
um
but can we do that later can we because
I first want to finish this point which
is which is right
um
I'm wrestling with this and the way I'm
wrestling with it is
um
first of all I I
I'm hoping that the work I'm doing
especially with a lot of other people to
integrate these kinds of theoretical
discoveries with ideas about the Deep
connections between predictive
processing relevance realization meaning
in life wisdom overcoming self-deception
all the sapiential stuff we've been
talking about
I'm hoping that because I've been
arguing for the connection that those
two things will stay wedded together
and
um
I don't know if I'm right about that
I I I I I like sometimes I get like uh
right I don't know if I'm right about it
um but right now I can't see I can't go
back
um and also I think there's so many
there was so much value I mean we
published the paper and we gave what we
thought was the first explanation of the
autism psychosis Continuum rather than
just description to think of the the the
the the the the the you know the the
psychotherapeutic and pedagogical
benefits that could have right so like
like but
um
I
I do hesitate about this about whether
or not my attempts to keep the science
and the spirituality wedded together
um uh you know there's no teleology to
for that to me I could
me and this whole Community with Sevilla
Kings calls this little corner of the
internet we're trying to do that we
could fail and I think that scares me
okay so don just to repeat
the question was about the limitations
of One's Own theories and then also I
saw your eyes light up on the mention of
morality and ego so you can comment on
that as I decide after it
sure sure so
I'll talk about my theory in just a
second but I'll just I'll just mention a
a classic case which is Einstein's
general relativity to deal with Quantum
field Theory right those theories assume
space time is fundamental in in their
fundamental concepts right Quantum
fields are defined over space time
Einstein's theory of gravity is is the
theory in which space-time is
fundamental and its curves are what we
experience as gravity so so space is the
fundamental concept that's going on
there so you might say well how can that
theory then say or entail that
space-time is doomed without
contradicting itself right I mean how do
we avoid shooting ourselves in the foot
well that's the glory of science because
when you put those theories together
they tell you precisely they say at 10
to the minus 33 centimeters
and 10 to the minus 43 seconds this
Theory stops it no longer makes sense
there are no operational meanings for
space and time at those levels so so
that's the beauty of those theories even
though Einstein didn't expect that to
come out
he didn't even expect black holes to
come out I mean it's the shortfield
found that solution to his equations so
when you take your ideas
even if you're a genius like Einstein
and you put them in mathematics you're
going to have your own Theory come back
and slap you in the face and tell you
things that you that you might not like
Einstein did not like black holes and I
think that he was unhappy with the idea
that that space-time ceased to have
operational meaning at 10 to the minus
33 centimeters my view is
that's what we want from a theory I love
a theory that tells you precisely at
like a 10 to the minus 33 centimeters I
stop and you need something new you need
a new tool so in our theory of conscious
agents so we have a theory of
Consciousness it's a mathematically
precise Theory and those who are
interested if you just Google objects of
Consciousness that's the title of our
paper and my name objects of
Consciousness in Hoffman you'll find the
paper it's it's uh it's
free online so no problem together so
that's a mathematical Theory Of
Consciousness it's just an I don't view
it as the final Theory of Everything as
I said it's just a next baby step in
science that's my view of the theory so
here's our next baby step but it's
mathematically precise and so the
question is does it tell me is precise
limits and it does and that's what one
thing that I love about the theory so
one theorem of the theory in this
current formulation is that anytime you
have
multiple agents multiple conscious
agents that that collection even if
they're not interacting that collection
satisfies the definition of a conscious
agent so it's a conscious agent
that's just a theorem
and what that theorem entails ultimately
is that there is one conscious agent
because all of the agents that you could
possibly have or combine and they create
a single new agent so there is
ultimately one one agent
but
here's the problem here's the limit of
our Theory
suppose I start with a countable
Infinity of conscious agents so agent
one two three four all the way up to
Infinity
well so I have this this countable
Infinity of Agents a left zero the
infinity
but now our theorem says that every
possible combination of Agents so agent
one and two one plus two that's an H of
one plus so it's the power set so
there's a a power set of new agents
well we know that the power set has
cardinality alf1 it's a new bigger
infinity
so now let's look at those agents and we
take all their combinations well that's
a new power set that's a lift 2.
so we're gonna have to go to get to a
description of the one
ultimate conscious agent that's the and
it's a theorem of our theory that there
is one conscious agent
we're gonna but to get to it to actually
describe it we're gonna have to climb up
all of cantor's hierarchy now there's an
infinite number of steps in Cantrell's
hierarchy which means we cannot get
there
so in 20 000 years if we're still using
this framework and we've gotten to level
five billion of cantor's hierarchy it's
time to break out the champagne we just
we went through 500 billion levels uh
you know we're at a lift 500 billion and
we learned a lot at every level so we
learned something new about
Consciousness every time we transcended
and went to a new level time to break
out the champagne how much further do we
have to go Infinity you're not even
you're not it literally you're not any
closer than when you started and yet you
learned a lot and so what I love about
this theory is it says there is the one
conscious agent and number two using
this Theory you'll never be able to
describe it but number three you'll know
precisely how far you've gotten and
precisely how infinitely far you have to
go at every step of the theory so the
theory itself predicts its own failure
to to actually describe an entity that
it's a theorem exists from the theory so
that for me that's one thing I love
about the theory is that it tells me
immediately how far I've gotten and
right now we're just at a left zero we
haven't even gone to lf1 yet
so we have a long way to go
John do you have any comments quickly
yeah
um
I wanna I wanna know more about what is
meant by conscious agents and what is
meant by
um the rejection of of space-time uh but
before I do that
um
I mean the arguments aren't identical
but they converge I mean these are very
in that sense convergent with
neoplatonic arguments that the one lies
beyond all possible
conceptualization uh and uh because
um
if
because if you tried to understand it
you have to understand it in terms of
its structure or its cause and therefore
you haven't actually achieved
um the the the the the the one because
you still would then have to get some
system of intelligibility that explains
the relationship between the structures
and the and so you're always you always
are pointing towards an Ultimate Reality
um that uh can't
ever be grasped the source of
intelligibility the arguments go like
the source of intelligibility can't
itself be intelligible
um and what was interesting is it
sounded to me Donald and maybe I'm
getting it wrong it sounded to me like
you got this sort of fractal wanting
going all the way up uh which means even
your notion of the one is in some sense
inadequate and it points Beyond itself
and then the whole trajectory of all
these ones points towards a one that is
never that is never graspable that's
what I heard you saying and that that
sounds like neoplatonism uh through to
me
um profoundly the part about the
conscious agents I want to talk to you
more about but the structure of sort of
you know I should do it this way the
fractal of winning like this or
something I don't know what what gesture
to make with my hands which is quite
adequate but that that is something
disclosed when you reflect deeply upon
intelligibility
um it sounds and by the way Donald I
hope you know that I mean this is a
compliment not an insult I consider
myself a post nominalist neoplatonist so
hearing what sounds like a very new
platonic structure to reality
that really resonated with me now I
wonder what you would say though
and maybe this goes to what you mean by
Consciousness so platinus argues that
the top thing right Consciousness is he
takes intentionality to be a feature of
Consciousness and that therefore
Consciousness always implies a duality
and that you need a one beyond that
Duality to explain
explain the Duality and that therefore
you pass beyond Consciousness and
thought you pass both the
unconsciousness and and intelligence
when you get to the when you get to the
want below it he has you know you
probably know this the new The Noose
which is like all of these ones all
those reforms that and they're they're
like this they're infinitely mirroring
each other like indra's net
um
so I want to I wonder what you think
about that kind of argument but I know
that's an unfair question to just ask
first because it depends on you know
what you're meaning by conscious and
what you're meaning by agent
right so
um and by the way I'll describe it but
of course the paper objects of
Consciousness has the math all laid out
in a shirt but
intuitively right when you're trying to
boot up a theory you want the the
smallest set of assumptions that you can
possibly use that would boot up a
general theory and there's dozens and
dozens of things you could think about
it you want a theory of Consciousness to
deal with you know the self is there a
self yeah learning memory problem
solving intelligence and there's a bunch
of things equalia possibility of free
will there's tons and tons of things so
but we can't throw in the kitchen sink
so what we do is we try to find the
minimal aspects of Consciousness that we
will take as the Miracles as the as the
fundamental assumptions of our Theory so
we took two we took that there are
conscious experiences
and the conscious experience has
probabilistically affect the other
conscious experiences occurring those
are the and I I just read in the last
few weeks of looking at the mode of
allergy it turns out leibniz says the
same thing he beat us by 300 years by
saying that those were the two if he was
going to boot up a theory of
Consciousness he would use those two
things the experiences and probabilistic
relationships among them so so what we
do is we we take that idea that liveness
beat me out uh 300 years ago and we
turned it into mathematics I say a
conscious agent basically is a
probability space of possible
experiences
so these this it could be an infinite
probability space so these are all the
possible experiences of this conscious
agent so write down the probability
space and and then I use markovian
kernels which is a very very general
formulation of some probabilistic
relationships so basically we have what
we call perception decision and action
kernels but they're all markovian
kernels and you can take their
composition and just have one more
clothing kernel if you want but we have
then basically a social network of these
probability spaces so related by
markovian kernels
so it's a big Social Network and and
it's a markovian Dynamics and and so
when you look at that Dynamics
um It's You Know It
that's what we mean by conscious agent
and it is a theorem of of that that when
you have two conscious agents
um you can take just their tensor
product and you will get a tensor
product of spaces and kernels and so
forth and and you get it it satisfies
the definition of a conscious agent but
but in terms of
Consciousness and some a deep thing
about Consciousness and and experience
I realized after we wrote it down that I
was forced by the mathematics to write
down a probability space on which the
experiences took place
so it's just sitting there it's like a
platonic structure just sitting there
what does that so I once later looked
back and said okay well what does that
mean about Consciousness well that's
clearly Consciousness prior to
experience
so that is that's we're forced to write
down in our mathematics a structure that
corresponds to a being without any
particular experience that is happening
so there is but then the markovian
Dynamics is really modeling the play of
forms of experiences that pop up and
down on this fundamental
um being that is timeless and uh
requires no experience it is the
field of potential for all experiences
so I realized later on that that
mathematics nicely intertwines with
interpretations that we see from various
spiritual Traditions but I was I I
didn't try to to you know model these
spiritual Traditions I was forced by
mathematics you can't talk about
probability until you write down the
probability space you just can't do it
and so so you're forced to do this and I
realized well the natural interpretation
of that is being prior to experience and
then markovian Dynamics is the full set
of experiences and now in the the issue
about mapping the space-time and space
time is doomed
what's going on there
um now I'm just going to tell you what
the physicists are saying they will say
the reason why space time is doomed is
this if you try to make
more and more precise measurements it's
smaller and smaller scales of space like
the position of this electron or
whatever it might be
you need to use radiation say light with
smaller and smaller wavelengths
that's fine quantum theory says that as
you use smaller and smaller wavelengths
you're going to have more and more
you're using more and more energy you're
concentrating energy into a smaller and
smaller space E equals H Nu is there is
the formula and that's and in a world
without gravity that's fine as long as
you can get more and more energy even
bigger and bigger Power Station you can
resolve smaller and smaller and smaller
things no problem so space space and
time are fine
gravity messes everything I was it's the
you know it crashes the party because
what happens is Einstein tells us that
energy and mass are the same thing so
effectively as you're making finer and
finer measurements you're you're
concentrating more and more mass into a
smaller region so you're getting higher
mass density
and then gravity says at some point when
you get when the mass density reaches a
certain threshold space-time collapses
into a black hole and the Very object
that you're trying to measure disappears
and that happens at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters and been 10 to the minus 43
seconds which is the amount of time it
takes to move 10 to the minus 33
centimeters and so so what happened and
so it and it's not like that there are
pixels of space time so a wrong concept
is always say oh well space time is
still fundamental but there are pixels
at that that level no no it means that
space time ceases to be coherent it has
no operational meaning at that level so
it just it's gone it's it's doomed
and another argument that the physicists
will give that's even deeper than the
one I just gave is to say that in
quantum theory the measuring device
itself is a physical device therefore
it's subject to Quantum uncertainty yeah
yes yes to get more and more precise
measurements you need to add more and
more degrees of freedom to the device
which means it's getting more and more
massive yeah if you're in the lab it's
you know you've got this device in your
lab at some point it's going to be you
know as you get more and more precise
the whole the mass is going to be so
great that the whole Lab collapses into
a black hole and again you destroy the
experiment so so there's no operational
meaning to space time and when the
physicists then say okay
space time has been good it's been
really a great framework for centuries
or you know space end time and then in
the last century space time but it's
time to find something new and there the
young physicists are moving beyond and
they found these new structures the
amplitohedron and then also the uh
decorated permutations
and these structures
um are Beyond space-time and they're
beyond quantum theory
and when I say they're beyond quantum
theory the amplitohedron has no Hilbert
spaces
but it's phase structure
encodes both locality and unitarity the
properties of space-time and quantum
theory so so this is a structure that
could have trillions or more Dimensions
Not Just 4 or 11 it has trillions of
dimensions and it doesn't care about
space it doesn't care about time it
doesn't care about Quantum Theory it
couldn't care less about them
but its volumes actually are
the scattering amplitudes if you want
the two blue ones in four gluons out the
the amplitude Heaton Associated to it
its volume is the scattering amplitude
and a space structure encodes locality
and unitarity
and so
so this is this is a structure Beyond
space-time and and here's the beautiful
thing
when you try to compute these scattering
amplitudes like two glons hitting each
other four glue ones go spring out if
you do it in space time
um well to do it in space time you have
to enforce things the properties of
space and time things you know have
locality and unitarity and so we have to
you know use what are called Feynman
diagrams to talk about all these virtual
particles that that we need in in
space-time to actually do this math it
turns out two gluons to four gluons
hundreds of pages of algebra hundreds of
thousands maybe millions of terms
to do one event just one event when you
go outside of space-time with the
amplitudehedron
that computation reduces to
three terms that you can compute by hand
so hundreds of pages reduced to three
terms so
and then all of a sudden the physicists
say by the way we also when we let go of
space-time we see these new symmetries
like something called the infinite
yanging and Symmetry and the infinite
yangian symmetry is true of the
scattering data and you cannot see it in
space time so space time is doomed
space-time forces you to do all this
nasty nasty computation that's that's
unnecessary the computations are
actually simple and it hides the
symmetries that are really true of the
data so so space time has three strikes
against it it proves its own uh
you know limits it it makes the math
unnecessarily complicated and it hides
the genuine symmetries that are there so
that's why
um the physicists are moving with both
feet Beyond space-time and they're
finding this wonderful stuff and and
that's why I as a as a you know a
theorist trying to get a theory of
consciousness
that can lead to testable results which
are only in space time right the only
place where we can get measurable
experiments is in space-time that's
where we get our measurements so
it's no longer
that I want a theory of Consciousness
that somehow you know emerging from
things in space-time like brains and so
forth that I mean space time is doomed
so that whole
that can't work so booting up
Consciousness from stuff inside
space-time the physicists are telling us
that will not work so I'm not going to
try to do that Consciousness is beyond
space time and they've given us this
the interface that we have to plug into
they've said we've gone beyond
space-time and the deepest thing we
found is a decorated permutation and so
a few months ago I was sitting there and
saying okay that's what the physicists
want they want to decorate a permutation
if I give them a decorated permutation
they can actually take me all the way
into space-time and give me a scattering
amplitude something I can test something
that you see at the Large Hadron
Collider so can I get from my markovian
dynamics of conscious agents to a
decorated permutation
and I looked online just to say well
surely the mathematicians have done this
you know for any markovian kernel what's
the decorated permutation now look and
there there's there wasn't anything
and so I work with my my mathematician
Penelope chaitan and uh didn't take us
very long we we so it's a new piece of
mathematics we now have a canonical way
of assigning every markovian kernel a
decorated permutation also any arbitrary
graph we can assign arbitrary graphs
decorated permutations
and what this does is it now the
physicists have pushed Beyond space-time
to decorative permutations but it's just
a platonic solid sitting there it's it's
motionless it's just sitting there
we now offer a Dynamics a markovian
dynamics that projects
so the Dynamics is much more complicated
so if we have for example
um 50 interacting conscious agents
the structure that we get the markovian
structure we get is a Markov polytope
with 50 to the 50th power
uh there's probably more than the number
of atoms in the universe that's the
number of vertices in this polytope
that's describing just 50 conscious
agents interacting so this is an
incredibly complicated structure very
very rich dynamical structure
that projects down that that that
structure which has you know more
vertices than all the atoms in the the
measurable universe
projects down into a decorated
permutation which is only 50 numbers
and that then gives rise to the
scattering so you can see that the the
conscious thing is really complicated
it's a really complicated Dynamics we're
collapsing it down to something trivial
when we get to decorated permutations
and then even more trivial when we get
into space-time
so so Consciousness is fundamental but
we have this map all the way from
Consciousness into space-time and so now
so we're submitting a paper this week so
the we finished writing the paper on
this which is why I'm pretty excited
about it we'll submit it um probably by
you know just before Thanksgiving um you
know Wednesday but we're now we have
this pontoon Bridge from Consciousness
into space-time and now what we're doing
is trying to do you know move all the
heavy equipment across so what what is
you know what
what aspect of consultation Dynamics
corresponds to energy and momentum or to
wavelengths or to spin or to helicity
and and so forth we we in our paper we
start to propose
specific
um correspondences between features of
Consciousness and its Dynamics in in our
in our model and specific things that
you can measure in space-time because my
goal is to show that you know the space
time is doomed yes
um but there's this dynamics of
Consciousness Beyond space-time and we
can actually predict specific scattering
amplitudes and actually show you where
spin momentum that helicity and all
these variables come from and and
I think we can even explain why
supersymmetry is false I think that in
our dynamical model we can actually show
why
um you know for certain models you
um
something called n equals four
supersymmetric theories
um the
decorated permutation gives you
everything there is to say about the
scattering amplitude everything
but if you don't have supersymmetry you
have to bring in spin and mass for
example and we can explain from our
dynamics of conscious agents why that is
the case that it turns out that the
different versions of spin are
asymmetric and you can't see it using
the standard physics models but when you
go through the markovian model you
actually see that spin the various kinds
of spins have subtle differences so that
they're not perfectly symmetric and that
then blows out supersymmetry so so we're
hoping not just to
um model what the physicists already
know but but to have the model actually
ex you know go go well beyond right
these these Markov polytopes have a
richness of structure and in our paper
we're only going to go after M3 the
three agent interaction which has 27 so
it's and it turned out my my colleague
caitan who's the mathematician
um worked very very hard as a beautiful
beautiful structure very very
complicated for just three agents
interacting and it grows exponential
with five agents there's three thousand
nodes three thousand more than three
thousand vertices it just grows
exponentially and the and the Dynamics
is very very rich so so that's a little
bit about why space time is doomed and
why I think Consciousness is is more
fundamental and why I'm sort of excited
about it
I have some thoughts I'd like to respond
to some of the technical aspects quickly
if you don't mind so you mentioned that
the amplitude hedron doesn't live in a
Hilbert space but it's unitary and it
doesn't presume space-time but it's
local so how the heck do you have
unitarity without a Hilbert space
uh well so so it's the structure itself
is not unitary and local it's just it's
just a um a geometric structure like a
polyte but not exactly a polytube but it
turns out that you can read off from the
the sort of like the lattice of like
facets and edges and faces and and
advertices from from that Arrangement it
turns out the physicists can actually
show that that corresponds to what looks
in space-time like unitarity and
locality
have you heard of the Coleman medulla
theorem
uh maybe but not I don't remember the
name so sure so it's a no-go theorem
about internal symmetries colloquially
they can't be combined in anything but a
trivial manner so if you have a point
array group the internal symmetries have
to be a direct product of them plus the
point array group for whatever reason
this is one of the reasons why
supersymmetry either must exist or
conformal symmetry must exist or you
need to be in a lower dimensional space
and so
I'm not a fan of supersymmetry but I'm
not a fan of any particular Theory so
I'm agnostic when it comes to many of
these physical theories which is why I
have a small bone to pick when you say
the physicists sure I want a decorated
permutation I want to say the physicists
I would say some physicists so anyway
then I would be curious like well how do
you overcome the Coleman medulla theorem
if you're doing away with supersymmetry
but you can look into that at some point
and then I'll also I'd like to take a
look at that article if you can send it
to me prior I can send you both of our
graph which is almost completed yeah
yeah
I'll look at the Coleman medulla Theory
does that theorem apply only to point
query spaces or a general theory about
geometric objects in general it's any
theory that has an S Matrix see if it
only place to point Craig group then
it's not a problem right
it is so because we're not we're not
stuck in space time we're not what we
have to do is show that deploying create
group comes out as a trivial projection
of a much deeper and richer structure I
mean our amplitude with with um you know
say a thousand agents
um is going to be a a polytope with a
thousand to the thousandth power
vertices
this is this is a this is this is not
the point great group this is something
truly mind-boggling this is a a very
very interesting polytopal structure it
includes by the way the berkoff polytope
is a sub
polytook within it so within the so the
berkeoff college was a very famous
polytrip of all the
um
all of its vertices are permutation
matrices
zeros and ones only in in the matrices
and and it's very very but that that is
a a subpolito of this Markov polytope I
have to stop you because Don mean you
have to have a solo podcast about this
as a part two to our previous one about
the details because right now I know
John is is your eyes may be glazing over
so you were championing at the bit
continue please
me yes yes yes yeah uh like
um
I think I followed a large part of that
although I don't know if I have the
physics background to uh say I grasped
all of it adequately
um I and I don't want to say anything
out of ignorance so I'll try and first
of all just ask some questions are the
are the are some of the physicists
Kurt's Point are they concluding that
space time
is not real or that it's emergent from
this more fundamental ontology like
those are two different claims
um right to claim that everything above
a fundamental level is not real is a
kind of reductionism that I've already
argued is I find very problematic
um I could but I wasn't clear which one
you're saying space time is doomed as a
fundamental or space-time is doomed as
an as an entity those are those aren't
the same claims uh so uh what are what
what are they saying yeah my take on it
is that um
I think that you know we could talk to
the physicists like Neymar Connie
Hibbett and so forth but my take is that
when he says space-time was doomed he's
saying that it's not fundamental
um right I I I I he may not want to
worry about deeper existential Notions
he's saying if you're a physicist and
you and and that was the framework in
which you're doing all your work that's
no longer the framework you've got to go
you have to show that there's a deeper
framework and that the um that space
time comes out as a projection of a much
richer and deeper framework now whether
he says that that means the space-time
is not real I I he I don't know if you'd
even be interested in that question I'm
not I'm just not sure um right uh
because for me I mean the idea that
space-time might be projected uh from
something that is not space-timey I mean
that's well you know and this is not
dismissive that's a perennial idea I
mean it's when you mentioned it it's a
it's a classic platonic idea uh that and
that you know that even to make
inferences that generalize we need
non-spatial temporal relations we need
Eternal relations I mean Berman makes
this argument this is why nominalism is
doomed and so and pardon me because it
sounds like these things you're
describing them geometrically
so given that given that geometry
figures are spatial
um does that mean that there's some
sense in which the language is
ultimately conceived as being imaginal
or metaphorical about this because you
know you're talking about faces and
you're using space-time language and and
Don I'm not trying to like pin you down
like a jiu jitsu but I wanted to get
people's attitude here what given that
they're using you know geometry uh as a
fundamental thing
um
like you know and Plato ran into a
similar kind of thing uh that's why I'm
asking this question uh what is it that
what what do they take their theoretical
representations to be
right so space time itself is just
another piece of geometry right it's
it's yeah so so you have the the
mathematics of polytopes or or
geometries more more generally and and
space-time and the point grade group you
know symmetries on space time and so
forth is is just one out of countless
different kinds of geometries most of us
our imaginations are so tied to
space-time it's hard for us to think out
outside of it but the you know the
amplitude for example itself it could
have trillions of Dimensions
um so it's it's it's so these are
geometric objects they're not objects in
a physical sense of some object in
space-time their mathematical objects
um and in the same sense that physicists
view space-time itself as being
described by a mathematical objects say
you know symmetry is the point grade
group and so forth so so it's that sense
that these are geometric objects but
I've had this question before because
people have asked me you know I gave a
talk at Stanford a few weeks ago on this
and someone said well so where are these
objects are they like at the plank scale
or are they stuck inside space-time
somewhere where where are they because
we all we if there's a geometric object
we think it has to be somewhere in space
and and this is the leap you have to
make no no space time itself is just one
fairly trivial geometric object
um and these objects are you know beyond
the transcend space time
um and they project it to space-time my
own view is that you know space time
from an evolutionary point of view on a
yeah I'd love to have a chance to talk
about Evolution with with John for in a
minute but from an evolutionary view I
think that that's that space-time is
just a virtual reality headset that
we've evolved and it's not a very good
one we we we have a cheap model it only
has four maybe 11 dimensions on this and
it it stops at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters it's very shallow it goes 10
to the minus 33 trillion centimeters I
might be impressed but 10 to the minus
33. so I feel like we got cheated we got
a really cheap um user interface and
it's shallow and uh and and I can't even
imagine uh you know a five-dimensional
object and for a lot of work I want to
do I would be very very helpful to
imagine a five-dimensional object and my
my little interface doesn't let me do
that so I have to actually then
painfully scratch down mathematics and
shaytan to do this little thing he spent
weeks and weeks you know because just
because we can't visualize you know this
this Markov polytope of three agents we
can't visualize we can't see a structure
we have to then painfully like filling
the different parts of the elephant you
know here's the tail here's the leg and
put together what this polytope is and
prove what it is so so you know
the space and time isn't a fundamental
reality it's a it's a a fairly low level
and cheap and shallow interface that
we're stuck with yeah I hope to
transcend it
so so what what is it you think about us
that gives us access
epistemic access to a
non-phenomenological reality I mean like
right and this then gets to the question
about evolution of natural selection too
and and so forth so
um
because I've argued on on evolutionary
grounds that we've been shaped not just
that you know our perceptions of space
and time are are fundamentally
um not correct right that there is is
not the truth it's just a user interface
and and that's what the physicists at
least these physicists are now saying as
well space and time is not the the
fundamental reality it's there's
something much deeper
so so argue for that
um in the following way Evolution but
natural selection is a it's a precise
mathematical Theory we have evolutionary
Game Theory evolutionary graph Theory
and so forth so it's a mathematical
model and we can ask clean technical
questions with that theory we can ask
the question for example
um what is the probability assuming
evolution by natural selection assuming
evolutionary game three what is the
probability that any sensory system
would be shaped by natural selection to
perceive any true structures of
objective reality
turns out that's a clean technical
question not a hand wave you can
actually ask that question using
evolutionary Game Theory and when you
ask that question it turns out it's a
theorem of the theory and in in the
paper that we have on this is called
fact fiction and fitness
um it was published a couple years ago
so if you just Google my name in fact
fiction and fitness the paper is free
you can you can read the proof the the
the the the the the the
probability is precisely zero and we
prove it for three or four specific
structures but when you look at it you
see the reason why and it's going to be
true for any structure the probability
is zero that any structure that you
might say the world the objective
reality might have the probability of
zero that any Fitness payoff function
will actually Preserve
the information of that structure will
be a homomorphism of that structure
so the probability that that the
payoff function that is shaping the
evolution of a sensory system actually
has any information about the structure
of the world is precisely zero so that
that payoff function couldn't couldn't
shape the sensory system to see that
structure in the world now so that's
just a theorem of evolution by natural
selection now do I believe evolution by
natural selection
I don't believe any Theory
I don't believe my own thirds I think
belief is the wrong attitude to have
towards scientific theories this so I
don't believe Evolution but natural
selection what I do believe is it's the
best story we have so far
and so that's why I took it seriously
with my team and we proved this theorem
but I'm happy to now
find a deeper Theory and then show that
evolution by natural selection uh arises
as a trivial projection and so and it
turns out I think we might be able to do
that so the theory of Markov chains that
we're using for conscious agents
that Dynamics does not need to have
increasing entropy
you can write down this easy write down
dynamics of conscious agents in which
the entropy doesn't increase and
therefore there's no entropic Arrow of
time
but it's a trivial theorem that if you
take this Dynamics which has no Arrow of
time
and projected onto a Dynamics
you know projection Dynamics via say
conditional probability it's a theorem
that when you do that the projected
Dynamics will have increasing entropy
it will have an arrow of time
so all of a sudden
and by the way that Arrow of time is not
an insight about the original Dynamics
it's not an Insight it's an artifact
of the information loss due to
projection
so what I would like to show is that
um evolution of a natural selection
all the limited resources time is the
fundamental limited resource
that is just an artifact of projection I
want to show that all of the appearance
of limited resources is an artifact of
projection
the appearance of competition
fighting for limited resources nature
red and truth and Claw and truth and
Claw is perhaps an artifact of a
projection of a deeper dynamics of
Consciousness in which there is no
competition there are no limited
resources and there is no Arrow of time
if we can prove that then this is how
science moves we would then take the
next baby Step Beyond Evolution but
natural selection so so here's the logic
I use because we are where we are I have
to use the tools of evolution with
natural selection to see its limits so I
use them and I find out it says to me
very very clearly
space and time and physical objects are
not the truth I cannot tell you what the
truth is but I can tell you this space
and time and objects are not the truth
that's a theorem of that theory
now I'm making the next leap I'm saying
okay I'm gonna propose the theory of
Consciousness beyond space and time and
in which there is no Arrow of time
but now I want to show is that when I
project that by conditional probability
I in special cases I get evolution by
natural selection as a trivial
projection of that and that's how
science progresses so that's how I can
use the tools of evolution of natural
selection to say that things like genes
and organisms and DNA are not
fundamental without contradicting myself
right that that's the logic that allows
me to use the theory to point to its own
limits and then transcend the theory
right to have a theory that in which
there is no error of time whose
projection leads to uh Evolution natural
selection or a generalization of it so
so that's that that logic that allows me
to look like I'm contradicting myself
I'm using Evolution to prove Evolution
doesn't work you're shooting yourself in
the foot no that's the way science pulls
itself up by the bootstraps each Theory
shows you its limits
if it's a good theory if it's not a good
theory it doesn't show you its limits if
it's a good theory it shows you its
limits you transcend the limits and then
you get your new Theory to project down
but now your question John which is how
what what what allows me to do all of
this what what what is the deeper
my feeling is
that
I
the the
entity that's doing all the science
he is not a physical object it's not a
brain it's not neurons
it is this unlimited intelligence
there is
so I am not an object in space and time
I am not neurons I am not any of that I
am that which comes up with theories
about space and time which comes up with
theories about neurons I am that which
can evaluate those theories and find
their limits and then transcend them and
get a new Theory that's what I am
I am that unlimited intelligence
and that unlimited intelligence does
transcend any Theory so that's the
framework in which I'm thinking about it
okay
um so let me ask you a couple questions
and then that was very helpful
um
so given that you agree that
all formal systems are are either
inconsistent or incomplete you can't
place an ultimate uh
I don't know what to call it faith in
even a mathematical model uh because the
read to which it has to limit and be
incomplete in order to avoid
computational interactability and all
kinds of other issues
um is through to which it's falling prey
to the very arguments you're making is
that not the case that's right so that's
why there's no Theory of Everything
exactly but what I'm asking is why why
the Prof the special privileging
and I'm asking this question honestly
because I do the same thing right so I'm
asking it of myself as well why the
special you know this is the question
posed to con right why the special
privileging of mathematical reasoning as
that which gives you access to reality
very very good I'll answer to two two
levels one is that the evolutionary
theorem level so because people have
said well if you use Evolution to show
that we don't know the truth then you've
you've you've shown that uh reason is is
nonsense and therefore you've shut
yourself on the foot yeah Alvin
plantinga for example a Christian
philosopher has tried to take that
argument to say that Evolution shows
that all of our cognitive capacities
um are are not reliable and therefore
our Theory building capacity is not
reliable and therefore the theory of
evolution is not reliable that's I was
thinking of playing tinga and I was
thinking of voter's response because
planting is in this really weird place
that he has to say most of our beliefs
are false yet there's some property of
the false beliefs that makes them
adaptive or makes them functional and
what would be that other than truth you
need you need to propose something other
than truth to say it's false but highly
functional and that's the that's the
missing property P of the propositions
that photo basically launches against
plantinga he says well tell me what it
is that the false beliefs have because
many of my false beliefs will kill me
readily right so it can't right there
has to be some property that
distinguishes false beliefs that are
non-adaptive from false beliefs that are
adaptive and what is that property
um that's that's the kind of question
I'm trying to get at
right right so I'll give two answers on
one I think if if I were planting of
what I would try to say is look I I
never believed in the theory of
evolution to begin with
I'm just trying to use the tools of
evolution to show that it's nonsense so
so I'm not subject to that kind of so if
I were planting I would make that move
right I I I never said that the
evolution is true and and I just wanted
to use it to show that it shoots itself
from the foot so so that's that's how I
I would
make that move but um
beyond that
again I don't think that
we can ever
any language so so there are limits of
mathematics I will say within the theory
of evolution so I'm going to just go
back to the theory of evolution itself
our theorem that says that Evolution
entails that none of our percepts are
vertical
it turns out that that theorem is only
for percepts for you know it's not for
logic and reason right and on
evolutionary grounds you could actually
have against planting Canal
um Arguments for why you should have
some facility with logic and reason for
example an organism that can notice that
two bites of an apple give you more
Fitness payoffs than one by Van apple is
better off
no that's about not about truth
about objectives about Fitness payoffs
something that's you know not about the
nature of objective reality so so there
would be some selection pressures You
could argue for some modest facility
with mathematics because you need to
reason about Fitness payoffs and every
once in a while the genes will come
together and you'll get a David Hilbert
or a Von Neumann and you get a
mathematical genius now so so you could
use that kind of logic against planting
but but you can see that I don't I don't
even want to go there because I'm saying
that evolution by itself I I also just
use the tools of evolution because it's
the our current best theory but I want
to completely transcend the theory with
something else that that projects down
to Evolution but but ultimately
any word or concept that we use and
including the most precise ones in
mathematics but I think that is it's not
just mathematics it's any concept that
we use I think will always as the
spiritual Traditions say always just be
a pointer and not the thing the the
finger that loses say the finger the
pointing to the Moon is not the moon and
that will be true of mathematics it'll
be true of of non non-mathematical
Concepts
so the bigger question for me is if I am
and you are this unlimited intelligence
that transcends Concepts why does that
unlimited intelligence
engage in using concepts for me that's
the big question
this this is the well first of all
um you're in good company this is an
ancient problem this is why this is why
does the one become Mini
yes right right this is this is why does
the one become mini and how could the
one become mini if the one is one right
and you're in that in that deep problem
so I don't want to I don't want to
saddle you with that and say you have to
solve that because right right because
that's unfair
um but what I'm trying to get at is
really I'm trying to get clear of your
model so we have some epistemic access
uh fallible as it is but that's not
that's not I'm not claiming
infallibility I'm hearing though that
there's still preferential the
conceptual access gives us prefer our
conceptual abilities give us
preferential access to reality over our
perceptual abilities I thought I heard
you say something like that so if I have
to choose between a percept and a
conceptual analysis I should give
priority to the conceptual analysis or
did I mishear you oh
well it's close what I said is within
the logical framework of evolutionary
theory that's the case right I'm not
saying that I believe I'm just saying
that using so when planting says let's
assume for sake of argument evolution of
natural selection
then you get that all cognitive
capacities are not reliable and I'm just
saying no no you don't you get the
perceptual capacities are not reliable
but you do not get that mathematical
account
so I'm just that's just an argument
about the specifics of evolution but but
I think I take your question as a
broader one than that yes
right so so so I want to distinguish my
argument on Evolution from the broader
question Evolution if you just take if
you ask what evolution says it says it
says clearly our perceptions are not
true it it it is doesn't say clearly
that our logic and math are not true it
doesn't say that clearly at all okay
but but why take it that
from this broader point of view
evolution by natural selection aside
um and now going Beyond any you know
even my own conscious agent mathematics
framework my own view is that
here I am talking using Concepts and I
know that every concept that I'm
speaking right now and every every
mathematical thought that I'm having is
not it and it's not even scratching the
surface of of the reality
all I can do is point to that fact and
and yet I do find myself because I'm
talking with you
and also talking to myself and trying to
understand things sort of forced to take
this unlimited intelligence
and compress it down to this almost zero
bandwidth thing that we call thought and
logic and Concepts
um and which the points to again this
this infinite so it's an infinite to one
or infinite to small thing and back out
to the infinite
and
so the question you know it comes down
to you why is there something rather
than just
presence without any content why why is
there content there's that and
um that goes back to a question about
um what experience means in your model
right right because what does experience
mean
um given what the way you're talking
um
but I wanna I wanna I wanna slow down
and and zero in on this
um
so
I I worry and I I I I I I I'm pretty
sure I must be wrong I worry that
there's an implicit thing that unless
you have all knowledge you have no
knowledge or unless you have all truth
you have no truth here the the idea like
I agree with you like and I've made this
argument multiple times I made it to you
know to hurt that you know the vast
amount of information we have to subtend
it we that's what relevance realization
is ETC I couldn't solve any of my
problems if I had to try and Trace out
all the probabilistic relationships to
all the other entities in the universe
blah blah blah I won't repeat all those
arguments I agree with that but I mean I
worry about things like mino's Paradox
and so righty's argument right which
says no no there has to be partial
knowledge that nevertheless grasp the
truth so why couldn't somebody say to
you yeah my perceptual knowledge is very
partial but that doesn't equate
logically with it being false it's just
partial because partial truth has to be
a thing or you're caught immunos Paradox
your cotton so write these arguments and
then you end up with absolute skepticism
and I can tell you're not an absolute
skeptic so I'm not going to voice that
on you but you see the point I'm making
partial knowledge doesn't mean false
just because it's partial that that
there has to be something more did that
make sense as a point oh absolutely and
I I think that partial knowledge is is a
perfectly good concept the the the but
but that knowledge is a
it deals with Concepts or math or both
yeah and and so the the
question is why would the one plunge
itself into partial knowledge so so
here's one view of what we are there is
the one Consciousness and it's putting
on is putting itself into different VR
avatars there's a John vervecki Avatar
there's a Don Hoffman but and there's
also a courage and so forth these are
all just avatars really
there's only one of us and it's the one
looking at itself through different
headsets
and and as I said I think this is a
cheap headset that is using this is only
four-dimensional it poops out at 10 to
the minus 33 is so this is the one
looking at itself through a fairly cheap
low grade headset I'm sure it uses much
higher ones as well right there are
countless other headsets that it uses
presumably to to look at itself and
explore so so
somehow
the one
is
and the way we experience it by the way
is I mean most of us don't think of
ourselves as the one we think of
ourselves as as this we identify with
the Avatar in the in the VR I am the
Avatar that's what I am and it's a very
painful process of waking up and
realizing oh no I'm not the Avatar I'm
the Consciousness in which the Avatar
exists I create the Avatar I thought I
was the Avatar I I am something deeper
that creates that Avatar and it's you
know so if that's what Consciousness is
doing the issue is why does
Consciousness plunge itself into the
ignorance why does it take a perspective
put on a headset
I asked a friend of mine
Perry pasaro of this question he said
you know maybe it has to do with love
right how can you love if there's only
one of you so what you do is you you put
on you you disunify yourself you put on
a bunch of headsets and now I can learn
how to to love John and Kurt and so
forth so I can learn how to be courteous
and and treat them properly and so forth
and in so doing that's what so in other
words if the one is love it it's in some
sense in the meaning of love to
diversify to to have the chance to learn
to love in practice I'm not saying that
that's right but it's the kind of deep
kind of question that you have to ask
and and kind of deep conceptual answer
you have to try to give to to answer
this kind of question
it sounds very similar to vedanta and
and Neil platonism So back when you
introduce love and love love both
differentiates and integrates so you get
the procession and the return and you
get to hold neoplatonic drama and then
you see cognition working fundamentally
that way right
um but here's where I here's I guess
where maybe and I'll speak
neoplatonically because I can't really
play in your physicist mathematics
framework because you you have me at a
tremendous disadvantage I'm trying my
best from where I'm at
um and I'm trying to be respectful of
the fact that I'm ignorant about some of
this but most neoplatonists would say
you ultimately have to say that the
emanation and the return are as real as
the one or you get into a really deep
profound uh kind of Duality which
undermines this fundamental
presupposition of the whole system so
that you know the the thing to use your
language the projection uh right and
what it projects are as real as what is
projected from because if there is
nothing projected then what it is
projected from wouldn't be intelligible
to us wouldn't we wouldn't have access
to it right because like let's even like
surely some of my precepts have to be
possible because I have to be right
because I'm reading the gauges on the
machines when I'm finding all of what
the physicists are finding and I'm
taking measurements and I'm correctly
hearing somebody when they're saying to
me no no look the implication of this is
right that's what I mean about you don't
want to get it into saying all of these
things that are going on within science
are somehow not real but you you didn't
hold a reductionism so if what I'm
saying is if you don't hold the
reductionism which you're nodding to and
and you know why not why not say that
the the procession and the return are as
real as the one I mean this is where
many neoplatonists ended up like aragina
right
um right I I like that approach and I
would love to see it work out in in the
mathematics of of our Theory actually to
sure as we start to look with bigger and
bigger systems and and look at the at
the one system and we look at this
Dynamics we may find that even though
these agents are one in fact when you
look at the net the one isn't just
static it's a dynamical system yeah and
when you look you'll find that it it
automatically has quote unquote these
parts these projections that are looking
at it from from different perspectives
and so it may end up being just um and
it may also be a consequence of again
girdles incompleteness theorem that says
that that there the end the exploration
of mathematical structure is completely
unbounded yes and that may also Force
the the one to always only be seeing
itself through perspectives because any
there may be some something very very
deep there that forces this as well the
fact that mathematics is
unbounded
so but but I feel like now I'm way over
my pay grade on this though we both are
but yeah that's fine where I mean first
of all I want to say something
um your view is much more sophisticated
that I've read it and been presented uh
I haven't read any of the papers but
I've read people presenting and I've
seen it and I think I may have
criticized you unfairly for example when
I was on Lex Friedman uh your view is
way more philosophically uh
sophisticated than I was getting uh to
be fair to me many people were
presenting your ideas and I and I was
like what I don't understand
um so first of all I owe you an apology
for that and I want to make that apology
right now publicly well well thank you
very much no problem
um so
um the next thing is it sounds like
I got like you I'm a follow-bus but I
I've come to the conclusion and I don't
I don't use certainty I use plausibility
and I have a formal model of what
plausibility means and I've articulated
that I think the idea that the
fundamental grammar of intelligibility
and the fundamental grammar of reality
have to be in some sense the same or you
cannot you you will be driven into kind
of an absolute solipsism and absolute
skepticism and it sounds to me like
you're saying something similar like
that like you're pushing the Machinery
of intelligibility to its fundamental
grammar sort of in the math and the
logic and then you're saying this is
somehow disclosing the fundamental
structure of reality if I can use that
term now is that a fair thing to say
about how you're proceeding yeah yeah I
would I I would say so with this very
humbling Proviso and that is that yeah
it is saying something about reality and
what it's saying is it may be measure
zero about the real reality right
probably in other words it's a it's a
probability zero subset of the whole
reality and that that we will in other
words
there's infinite job security in science
or at least in philosophy yeah
that's right it's infinite job security
because we will always have only just
begun
um it will always add we'll have
essentially a measure zero
grasp of the hole but that measure drill
may be real I mean it may be genuine but
it'll be measure zero right
I I I don't think I'm objecting to that
but I also want to I want there to be
some important continuity between
whatever judgments I'm making about
Ultimate Reality and judgments when I
say this is more real to me than the
dream I had last night I don't want
there to be uh like because if you do
that you're you're sneaking in a magic
epistemic engine somewhere right right
and that that I think we we have we have
to we have to we can't allow it's like
no no I'm using I'm using the same
epistemic engine there has to be
important continuity uh between when I
make those judgments about you know this
is more real than the dream I had last
night I'm using that same thing in some
way when I'm making the judgments about
that that you're making about the one
and and I I agree okay I agree and maybe
part of that coherence is the
recognition explicitly
that everything that I deal with
conceptually is a limited thing that may
be one of the key things to make that
coherence yes is the explicit
recognition of the limit of any
statement or any Theory
your your epistemic humility
um
I just want to acknowledge it
um that's I mean don't misunderstand me
Donald I mean the content of what you're
saying um is is Rich and you know
rigorous and I I but I think your
epistemic humility was something I had
not got
um uh right before but I'm seeing it in
our conversation here
um I yeah you and I resonate I think
very deeply at that level I sort of in
an implicit way asked Donald the
question and I don't want to try and
answer it now because I think it would
take us into more but I'd be happy to
talk to him again about this use of the
word experience and and and and and I'm
also what's the relationship between
experience and conceptuality or
intelligibility how are they right and
right there's a lot there I think uh
that can be
um unpacked but um absolutely and I'm
I'm enjoying talking to you Donald
because like you're very open I hope
you're finding the same with me you're
very absolutely very responding you know
that you the arguments are going back
and forth
um but uh so I'd like to I'd like you uh
explore that um aspect of your thinking
with you if possible I would love to do
that I'd love to get back together all
three of us and and and jump into that
with both feet that'd be a lot of fun
absolutely and I really appreciate uh
John ankert the the open-mindedness and
I mean Dogma Justin kills things but
open mindedness really a rigorous
open-mindedness right where your heart
knows no no second rate logic you want
everything to be clean that's that's how
we make progress and I really appreciate
that spirit thank you excellent by the
way do you know somalian's theorem that
we're all either arrogant or
inconsistent
[Laughter]
it's actually extremely simple your
brain is finite we can agree on that and
even this this works even if it's
infinite but it makes it much more
simple so you believe in proposition a
you believe in proposition ba
down to proposition n not n as in the
14th letter but you understand so you
either then believe that every one of
your beliefs is true in which case
you're arrogant or you believe that one
of these propositions is incorrect you
just don't know which one which means
that somewhere you have a belief that
you believe it to be true and you
believe it to be false which means
you're inconsistent so you either are
arrogant or you're inconsistent well I
don't know how old this theorem is but
in the 80s in minimum rationality he
argued uh you can't even given uh the
the time it is to move one valence shell
than the rest of the history Universe
you can't even calculate of 138
propositions are logically consistent
with each other
um because of all possible implications
blah blah blah it just right so the
finitary predicament I think is one of
the things I like about the platonic
framework
is it is this continual profound not
just talking but profound realization
that we are simultaneously fitting to we
are simultaneously finite infinitive but
capable of transcendence
um and if we if we lose the first we can
give into hubris and if we lose the
Transcendence we will give in to Despair
and servitude and trying to keep the two
together at all times
um so I look for people that are that
in addition to what they're saying there
is how they're saying it and
and I mean this is a compliment Donald I
was I I was surprised don't take this as
the wrong way I was surprised to get
that sense from you I get I kept hearing
you going between you know this is how
we can transcend our experience and then
back to where finite we're fallible and
you kept toggling back between them
every time you were giving an answer and
you were trying to do it and as you said
not sloppily or right but but you were
trying to do it very carefully and I
appreciated that
um
um yeah this uh this was this was this
was really I really enjoyed this
a lot of fun and I I love this
discussion I'd love to have it continue
absolutely
thank you all thank you all for coming I
appreciate it and we'll do it again next
time excellent
what a pleasure thank you what follows
is an excerpt of a conversation between
John and myself that was partially
recorded regarding truth Framing and
what salutary that is truth isn't an
object to be picked but it's also the
act of picking these arguments from
Oneness actually are left brain
phenomenon that we tend to think of that
it is spiritual and creative but it's
more from Ian mcgilchrist Ian
mcgilchrist would say that that our left
brain likes to categorize and see
sameness and that the right brain likes
to see distinctness and uniqueness
because I have this huge solipsistic
moment and and it was extremely
frightening and terrifying to me I'm
still recovering from that I'm like the
best I've been Ian told me something
helpful which is that hey you share an
element with God and you share an
element with other people and that that
doesn't mean you are and the fact that
you share implies you're different
because you can't share with yourself
well that's what I want I want to talk
to Donald about what he means by
experience and like leibniz had the
problem that the monads are
self-enclosed but yet somehow they have
Windows which is trying to make this
work but he was very I mean like he said
no you know but the procession and the
return are just as real as the one and I
think that's right that's an important
thing to him for him to acknowledge yeah
yeah and I also get that when people say
that so-and-so is an illusion yeah but
in another sense it's it's real but but
he admitted that too when like yeah when
all the all the scientific observations
have to be real and partial knowledge is
real like like his his notion of it
being illusion is is not that notion
it's not the solar systemic notion
um yeah well like I said hear very
deeply the conclusion that Donald Act
was in agreement with which is the
procession and the return are just as
real as the one
right uh right and and so the idea that
this is all an illusion behind or in
front of the world that's not this is as
much the one as the one is the one right
or it's not the one right and so it it's
it's it any I would challenge you
whenever that idea is giving you a
profound sense of separation or
disconnect you have misframed the idea
or people have missed right to you
misframed it to you what's salutary and
what's nourishing what's true isn't
always just the the static proposition
to be grasped and that somehow this this
Compass of either trying to direct
yourself someplace or even caring that
you're directed properly that there's a
truth in the process
and so when people say hey if you find a
toll won't you be bored well maybe the
toe the true toe is like something like
live like live in a certain manner oh it
has more love if you think that there's
non-propositional knowing which I think
deeply there is and it's more primordial
and important to your cognitive agency
than propositional knowing you're not
going to capture it if you by Theory you
mean you know your set of propositions I
did say I don't think of theories just
as formal systems uh that doesn't make
any sense to me I think their theories
are better understood as interpretations
and bridges of our formal propositions
into the other kind of knowings that's
what I think theories actually do for us
the podcast is now concluded thank you
for watching if you haven't subscribed
or clicked on that like button now would
be a great time to do so as each
subscribe and like helps YouTube push
this content to more people also I
recently found out that external links
count plenty toward the algorithm which
means that when you share on Twitter on
Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you